much of pregnancy and postpartum care is
focused on the baby which can leave
mothers without many of the resources
and support that they need it's
estimated listen to this number that one
in four pregnancies ends in a
miscarriage though that number experts
believe could be much higher about one
in eight women have infertility issues
many also struggle with postpartum
depression not to mention trouble
feeding their babies and judgment and
stigma from other people on pregnancy
and child care practices everybody has
an opinion
the company poppy seed health offers
one-on-one access to their doulas
midwives and nurses 24 hours a day with
various pricing options founder and ceo
simone tate started the company after
her own experience with laws good
morning to you simone tate really good
to have you here i think this is such an
important conversation there's a lot of
stigma and shame and i'm hoping that
you'll help eliminate some of that today
so this is a really personal story for
you
what happened it is deeply personal for
me so i want to take you back to 2016
when i had my first pregnancy loss first
my first i've had multiple sins and i
was at my doctor's office first thing in
the morning
in my first trimester and we couldn't
find a heartbeat
and instead of getting the kind of care
and comfort that i thought i deserved in
those moments my doctor looked at me and
said that my body had terminated my
pregnancy
which was like a dagger that's the heart
that phrase that phrase
it was horrific but then she followed up
and said but it's normal
it's fine i'll see you in a few months
when you start trying again and she left
the room and you're just sitting there
and i was sitting there not just sitting
there i was devastated i was crying i
was deeply emotional i was in a
state of shock and and denial because i
had come in pregnant and i had just
found out that i wasn't pregnant anymore
and then in a way she sort of blamed you
your body terminated the pregnancy this
was 2016 you said you've had multiple
have multiple miscarriages have you been
able to have a baby i have not been able
to have a baby and just these stats here
are devastating we just don't know it
that one in four people will experience
a pregnancy loss during their
reproductive years
and i'm always trying and any way that
family happens for me well we'll make it
happen i think it'd make it more painful
for you to discuss it you know yeah sure
i mean women have difficulties before
pregnancy during pregnancy and then
after and it is so fundamentally true
that there are resources for the baby
but not as many for the mother and now
we have midwives doulas and nurses i
think people know what nurses do talk
about mid-lot midwives and doulas if you
could well most people who have doulas
will tell you that they couldn't have
gotten through their pregnancies labor
and delivery and postpartum without a
doula we are trained emotional and
mental health and well-being best
friends for you we are your advocates we
can fill in the blanks in places that
you have no idea with evidence-based
information and that emotional support
that only you can go to and our midwives
are holistic caregivers they are medical
providers who really focus on the whole
person and not just the baby and that is
so important that's what we do at papa
you know what focus on you it's been 34
years since i've had a baby i never even
heard the phrase to be honest with you
duelist but i don't know anybody that's
had a doula favorite daughter kirby
included that doesn't regret that that
doesn't regret that they had a doula
they said it's life-changing and
game-changing and for that reason we
think everyone should have access to do
so what do you do with poppy seed then
sure so we are a 24 7 on-demand texting
health tech company so anytime you text
with us in 90 seconds or less one of our
doulas midwives and nurses from all over
the country will be in a one-on-one
immediate conversation with you to meet
you where you are with your emotional
and mental health support so at 3 00 a.m
in the morning when the baby isn't
latching or you're feeling anxiety or
you can't sleep you can come to poppy
seed health and we are there for you
instantaneously it's an incredible
service that is so needed
for women but you know when you look at
the support that they will have with
poppy seed
sometimes the outside world doesn't give
that same type of support gail mentioned
the stigma miscarriages infertilities
sometimes you could look in the mirror
and have your own inadequacy but then
there's judgment from the outside world
i don't know i'm just a man on the
outside looking in why is there so so
much judgment when it comes to all of
these things that women have to deal
with and oftentimes from other women
that's right you know the judgment and
the narrative around stigma and shame
we've got to end it but it starts with a
cultural shift we are not taught that
we're sitting next to someone who might
have just experienced a pregnancy loss
we're not taught how to support someone
who's going through ivf and those
hormones can send you through the wall
sometimes starting with the kind of
cultural shift in the narrative which is
so important
also includes us being vulnerable and
meeting people where they are with their
emotional mental health support as part
of their healthcare journey and so we
oftentimes
create guides and tell people and share
with people the ways that they can
support their their loved ones what do
you think men can do absolutely
get this service i think you do good
that's exactly right partner support is
family it's crucial exactly it is so
important for health outcomes for the
support of the entire family and what
happens on the other side of starting a
family we've got to go why do you call
it poppy seed oh well gail poppy seed
health
poppy seed specifically is the size of
an embryo at the very beginning stages
so poppy seed health is with you
no matter what the outcome is pregnancy
postpartum or loss yes thank you simone
thank you so much that's very important
information